bonjour la voie est libre tous les
samedis en direct sur france 3 et ce
matin nous avons décidé de nous pencher
sur la voie des militants la voix des
citoyens pour désigner les candidats les
primaires on se souvient de la primaire
médiatisée du ps en 2011 la droite a le
même projet pour novembre 2016 la gauche
a elle bien du mal à se mettre d'accord
est ce une rénovation de la démocratie
est ce un piège est ce une arme fatale
pour gagner une élection
nous allons en débattre avec philippe
baumel député ps de saône-et-loire
bonjour bonjour
catherine hervieu vous êtes vice
présidente europe ecologie les verts du
grand dijon
bonjour bonjour christine robin
conseillère régionale de saône et loire
vous êtes vous membre de l'ue des
e-bonds jours d'un jeu et eric gentil
conseiller régional de l'yonne pour les
républicains
bonjour bonjour vous soutenez bruno le
maire en vue des primaires de la droite
novembre 2016 donc après la primaire
organisée par le ps en 2011
à l'époque sur s'en souvient c'était
beaucoup sur le modèle italien la droite
a donc décidé de faire la même chose en
novembre 2016 la question est donc
simple est ce devenu obligatoire quand
on est dans l'opposition de désigner son
candidat par une primaire
moi je pense que c'était déjà un bon
moyen effectivement de désigner son
candidat pour les élections
présidentielles c'est vrai qu'en 2011
nous nous étions un petit peu moqué de
la gauche quand elle à organiser sa
primaire mais il ya eu un débat après
vous êtes pas après on sait mais on sait
moins moquer effectivement au printemps
suivant et donc nous avions pris la
décision d'organiser des primaires pour
les prochaines échéances
et moi je trouve que les primaires ça va
être un beau moment de politique de vie
démocratique où on va pouvoir discuter
mais toutes les toutous les sujets sur
la table
et puis après nous choisirons un
candidat les 20 et 27 novembre et nous
devrons être tous derrière ce candidat
philippe baumel jeu prononcer le mot
élan tout à l'heure vous vous l'avez
vécu de l'intérieur au parti socialiste
en 2011 est ce qui effectivement une
primaire surtout quand on est dans
l'opposition parce qu'on va parler on va
en parler après mais quand on est dans
l'opposition c'est une primaire ça donne
un élan que vous n'aviez pas connus
avant dans une campagne ça donnait là
parce que c'est d'abord un débat sur des
projets différents et ça veut dire que
les militants d'abord où les
sympathisants peuvent choisir
véritablement une personnalité mais lié
à un projet parce que ça avait nourri en
2011 un véritable débat sur un projet
présidentiel
et ça avait donc parfois clarifier les
idées écarter certaines idées aussi et
on avait vu une progression dans ce
débat aussi de façon très gratuit à
partir des débats télévisuels d'ailleurs
qui avait été organisée donc c'est très
utile alors appris à des circonstances
qui sont les nôtres aujourd'hui qui à
mon avis exige que fred précisément dans
les deux camps ces primaires soient
organisées
parce que si elle ne l'était pas à mon
avis on va courir en danger extrême
inquiet jeudi extraits ne sait pas par
hasard et bien sûr on va y venir bien
sûr la position particulière du parti
socialiste europe écologie en 2012
c'était 2010 2011 afin primaire aussi
bien avancé du parti socialiste est-ce
que al'inverse la vôtre on se souvient
nicolas hulot eva joly est ce que ça n'a
pas à linverse casser la dynamique de
l'élection derrière est-ce que parfois
la primaire ça peut pas être ça non je
pense que pour rebondir ce que vient de
dire philippe bonnel on était tout à
fait dans le portage du projet
l'incarnation pour une adéquation projet
et ouverture auprès de auprès de la
société des électeurs et tout donc
c'était une première
cinq ans après effectivement qu'il faut
recommencer parce que cinq ans après
aussi au delà de ce qui s'est passé
pendant la préparation des
présidentielles de la présidentielle et
des législatives il ya aussi que ce qui
s'est passé après voilà donc ce qui
s'est passé après eh ben on est tous
ceux ci dans le constat d'une conclusion
quand même généralisée d'un grand
questionnement je parle même pas de la
déception au niveau du contenu des
actions qui se passe ou donc la primaire
par contre je dois être utilisé dans une
classe
idéologiquement les choses en main par
clarifier à la fois une adéquation du
projet et pouvoir aussi se donner les
moyens de l'appliquer et de ne pas
retourner dans retourner vers les
français en
en agitant en confortant une grande
déception qui existe actuellement et qui
nous amène dans une situation à la fois
paradoxal confuse et à qui interroge
aussi les institutions je pense que dans
le débat faudra quand même qu'on parle
de cela dessus dessous gouvernement
bicéphale qu'il soit de gauche ou de
droite
mon frère michael le pays actuellement
mais effectivement ça nous y amène bien
sûr que je posais la question au début
est ce que c'est une façon de rapprocher
aussi les citoyennes et citoyens je veux
dire voilà pour les primaires organisées
par le ps pardon on peut parler des
autres aussi évidemment mais je me
souviens qu'à peu près 4 millions de
gens qui avaient voté aux tours
successifs
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya eu un
engagement citoyen très fort qui s'était
développée de façon assez spontané et
qu'avec est d'ailleurs assez difficile
d'organiser mais qui avait été organisée
et qui avait donné une véritable force
au candidat choisi
moi j'ai envie pour nommer d'abord
d'atteindre 20 de faire avancer notre
discussion sur qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une primaire ce doit être la primeur
d'un parti ou est ce doit être la
primaire d'une famille politique et bien
sûr vous voyez où je veux en venir
christine robin on sait que plus d y
goûter nearly a décidé de ne pas pour
l'instant qu'à participer à la primaire
que va organiser alors vers la droite va
devenir la primaire des républicains
manifestement il ya un risque ou à
partie - gros qu'un autre d'aller
participer à une primaire c'est comme ça
qu'on peut le dire je crois que notre le
les institutions en france la
constitution telle qu'elle est existe
aujourd'hui fait que effectivement on
retrouve au deuxième tour deux candidats
qui s'affrontaient donc il ya forcément
on réduit finalement la la la famille
politique à deux grands blocs donc dans
ce cadre là on ne comprendre le sens des
primaires mais à condition que ça ne
soit pas simplement fait pour départager
quelques candidats d'un même parti mais
quant à elle plutôt sur des plate forme
programmatique où effectivement il y as
derrière des accords d accord de
gouvernement des accords d'alternance
quand il s'agit de de reprendre le
prouvera qu'il reste ça comme ça mais il
faut bien qu'à ce moment-là ce soit sous
l'angle des idées des choses des valeurs
que chacun défend et essayer de trouver
un socle de valeurs communs qu'ils
soient en partage et ça ça doit devenir
à mon sens la priorité
parce qu'autrement on va peut-être vers
l'écueil que l'on connaisse sur ce
mandat là où globalement quand les
accords sont peut-être pas suffisamment
solide ou pas suffisamment discuté ou
réfléchie et ben on arrive à un moment
donné un échec l'attend on va y venir
assuré pour rebondir je vous donner la
parole est ce que tout ça n'est pas lié
aussi aujourd'hui à l'après au 21 avril
2002 à la présence du front national
traditionnellement premier tour en
france il pouvait y avoir quinze
candidats en gros on éliminer au premier
on choisissait au deuxième
la possibilité pour le front national
d'accéder au deuxième tour remporté une
élection c'est ça qui change qui vous
pousse à vouloir choisir avant les
gentils effectivement de toute façon la
vie politique a évolué ces dernières
années avant nous avions deux grands
blocs droite gauche et maintenant nous
avons trois parties la gauche la droite
et le front national extrême droite et
ses trois parties peuvent accéder au
deuxième tour
donc c'est vrai que maintenant nous ne
pouvons plus multiplier les candidatures
au premier tour parce qu'on l'a bien vu
avec l'exemple de lionel jospin qui a
été éliminée dès le premier tour lors
des présidentielles
donc on doit choisir au préalable et où
je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
ce que vous dites lorsque vous parlez
des primaires des républicains ce sont
les primaires de la droite et du centre
parce que les gens qui vont aller voter
ce ne sont pas que les militants
républicains mais ça va être beaucoup
plus large pour susciter également un
élan comme ça a été le cas en 2011
il faut poser la question aujourd'hui de
savoir c'est ce qui se passe si n'ya pas
primaire s'il n'ya pas primaire pour le
temps qu'ils n'organisent pas les
primaires c'est de toute façon l'échec
assuré
c'est la division qui va régner jusqu'au
premier tour et c'est aussi le retour
aux petites combines celles qu'on a
connues depuis le début de la vème
république qui fait que en touillant
dans son petit pot en marchant de
quelques circonscriptions pour calmer le
partenaire on lui dit tu dois te
demandent 50 circonscriptions tanora 30
et on va on va alors on va s'arranger
entre nous le cep ce système aujourd'hui
que les français refusent parce que les
français au contraire je crois qu'ils
sont un peuple éminemment politiques
veulent avoir une clarification du
projet pour choisir précisément des gens
qui vont porter ce projet à la suite
donc on a une évolution
institutionnel qui s'est passé à travers
d'être la mise en place des primaires et
qui à mon avis en ricochet doit
entraîner d'autres ensuite probablement
pour aller jusqu'à une modification de
la constitution et peut-être aller vers
une autre république mais on y va on est
sur ce chemin là d'ores et déjà la
question quand même ses militants ou
sympathisants parce que depuis le début
on parle de primaire ont voilà vous avez
contrer en disant mais c'est la primaire
de la droite c'est pas celle d'hier la
cub ligue 1 mais c'est quand même ça la
question c'est est ce que il ya une
grosse différence entre demander à ses
adhérents ou allait demander au delà de
ses adhérents et vous avez toutes les
deux répondre dessus oui tout à fait
c'est je crois que c'est un sujet majeur
on voit il ya la question des partis
dont on dit qu'il ya une désaffection
généralisée sauf peut-être pour le front
national
donc ça c'est s'interroge chacune de ne
se pas de primaire et qui monte dans les
élections irie c'est parce que c'est
vraiment une autre logique très bonne at
artistes voire plus
en bref la question de la primaire par
rapport aux costumes à classique qui
vient d'être décrit ce ouvrir s'ouvrir
sur la société est demandé aux personnes
au delà des militants demandent aux
électeurs au delà des militants
qu'est ce qui vous semble par rapport au
projet et par rapport à l'avenir du pays
par rapport à comment se projette à 5 10
ans dans ce pays qu'est ce que vous
mettez qui doit incarner en lien avec
une adéquation avec le projet et que ce
soit réservé comme ça a été pendant très
longtemps aux militants prêts qui sont
plus ou moins spécialisés de combines de
et ses mensonges france d'être trop
péjorative
mais que ce soit la sphère de tous les
français et françaises qui souhaitent
s'y impliquaient c'est quand même une
aspiration et donc la primaire est un
outil c'est pas une fin en soi
de même que le parti politique c'est un
outil ce n'est pas une fin en soi et
parfois le nez sur le guidon on a
tendance à oublier on en fait vraiment
des machines au delà de désespoir au
delà de ce qu'il faudrait faire et
notamment pour le changement climatique
il ya un lien peut-être deux points un
peu différent le premier segment
traditionnellement l'élection
présidentielle et le premier tour de
l'élection c'est la rencontre de tous
les chaque partie peut effectivement jeu
georges est d'une certaine façon à
l'aune de l'autre des autres élections
ce qu'on peut se compter aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que le 21 avril à bousculer
un petit peu les choses parce que
effectivement ça fait prendre des
risques à certaines familles politiques
ça peut être ça pourrait être
alternativement la droite ou la gauche
ça a été la gauche attend ça pourrait
être la droite demain et c'est faire
prendre le risque à cause de la montée
du front national très clairement quand
au moment où le front national arrive à
dépasser les 20% ça lui donne au groupe
une capacité d'être au deuxième tour et
ça change la donne est donc dans ces cas
là la primaire elle pose elle prend du
sens pour essayer d'anticiper finalement
le deuxième tour et d'opérer des
rassemblements de famille ou de force
politique avant le deuxième tour
mais encore faut-il que dans ces cas là
il ya une vraie discussion sur le fond
et que ça ne soit pas l'hégémonie
simplement des partis les plus
importants mais qui est une ouverture de
qui s'exprime
bon vous avez décidé donc pas pour
l'instant c'est pour ça que si vous
voulez il ya deux temps dans la
manoeuvre il ya la première le premier
temps qui est quelque part une stratégie
de parti je prends l'exemple de lully
ces essais le rôle pour le coup des
militants de décider de choisir quelle
est la stratégie que l'on veut adopter
et et ça c'est d'une certaine façon
c'est les militants du parti qu'ils
l'expriment et ensuite à partir de à
partir de cette position là peut-être
des règles ou dieu des préalables qui
sont énoncées en exerçant à dire
préalable de voir comment est-ce qu'on
peut arriver au processus de la primaire
où là on est davantage à rechercher une
validation par des gens plus large que
simplement les mustangs
mais bon je large moi je sois une
frilosité quand même bien marqué dans
les propos de marc robin parce que son
parti a décidé en vérité pour l'instant
de ne pas y participer
l'un accompli de manoeuvre en bord de
voie là et plutôt d'aller manoeuvrer
derrière le rideau en quelque sorte pour
essayer trouvé un accord avec son grand
partenaire des républicains moi je pense
que c'est des méthodes un peu datés et
tout ça est qu en vérité les français
aujourd'hui attendent beaucoup de
transparence dans dans ce que 10 des
inscrits vont faire des acteurs plus
politique pour les années à venir
on ne peut pas
voir un grand talent et une grand
rassemblement si précisément le jeu
consiste à faire je ne sais qu'une
stratégie d'étape en étape qui va donner
le sentiment finalement au moment où on
va appeler les français à venir voter à
une primaire que finalement le choix est
déjà fait ça c'est très sexy pardonnez
moi puis bovell avant de vous donner à
part vous renvoie la primaire de 2011 ou
ps ou françois hollande a besoin d'
arnaud montebourg ont fait qu' il ya une
différence énorme il est logiquement
entre françois hollande et arnaud
montebourg pour autant il va passer un
accord avec arnaud montebourg qui va le
suivre pendant plus de deux ans dans son
programme
est-ce qu'on n'est pas exactement dans
la même chose c'est-à-dire que pour
gagner la primaire on est amené à faire
des choix qu'on va traîner par la suite
soit pas qu'on soit dans la même chose
du tout parce qu'en vérité la primaire
est serrée elle s'est réalisée en
transparence a eu des débats publics
encore une fois il ya eu des dégâts lui
défait qu'enfin des faits et des idées
qui ont jalonné le choix du candidat
il ya eu un certain nombre d'engagements
d'ailleurs du candidat qui a été choisie
sur des méthodes et des projets ont-ils
tous étaient venus
c'est ce que dira d'ailleurs la campagne
des primaires parce qu'il y aura
problème avant probablement un
inventaire france par nos mondes au
népal n'a pas quitté le gouvernement
pour rien il y avait une amende à ce
moment là une stratégie qui avait été
décidé notamment sur le plan économique
et industriel c'est très stratégie
malheureusement n'a pas été tenu pendant
que je vois donc il faut carrément donné
reconnaître les faits donc je crois
vraiment qu'il ya eu un débat public un
débat très fort qui a d'ailleurs été un
débat assez houleux
on s'en souvient quand même un tout ça
ne se faisait pas dans une béatitude
parfaite mais c'est a été publique est
ce que la donner le sentiment aux
citoyens que finalement il se fait
véritablement non seulement leur mot à
dire mais un véritable choix pour les
années à venir à faire c'est justement
ça nous amène sur un chantier dont je
voulais qu'on parle celle des risques
finalement de la primaire je me tourne
vers vous et eric gentil la gauche a
l'habitude de ces déchirements de
plusieurs semaines et cicatrices très
bien en général après vous en avez
beaucoup moins l'habitude à droite on se
souvient c'était pas une primaire la
désignation entre jean-françois copé et
françois fillon qui a été
difficile vous avez mis beaucoup de
temps vous en remettre est-ce que vous
de votre point de vue ça vous fait peur
est-ce que vous pensez que votre parti
est mature pour gérer ce type de moment
ou pas moi je pense que notre parti est
tout à fait mature pour gérer ce type de
moment
vous parlez de l'épisode copé fillon ont
ceci on vient un petit peu plus loin en
arrière on a eu un épisode aussi entre
ségolène royal et martine aubry donc
dans chaque partie il ya des moments
difficiles qu'il faut passer une certain
terminer devant les tribunaux tout à
fait qu'il faut contrairement au
programme et il faut qu'il faut
surmonter
je pense que nous nous aurons moins de
soucis à droite et au centre
parce que nous ne sommes pas contraints
à un grand écart
parce que à gauche il ya quand même des
différences très importantes entre les
différents acteurs vous citiez arnaud
montebourg manuel valls on a quand même
des prises de positions qui sont
vraiment très différentes et après c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de mélanger
toutes ces personnes là pour maintenir
un cap d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu
françois hollande avait annoncé
certaines choses de façon très
démagogiques
quand il a dit dans son discours du
bourg du bourget que son adversaire
s'était la finance ou qu'il allait
inverser la courbe du chômage
moi je pense que tout cela ça
décrédibilise la politique et les hommes
politiques parce qu'on lance des grandes
phrases et on est incapable d'arriver à
un résultat
donc il faut changer les choses nous
pour les primaires de la droite et du
centre nous avons un texte d'orientation
qui a été validé par les principaux
responsables de notre parti nous
engageons les discussions avec l'ue dei
qui n'a pas fermé la porte
et tout cela va se faire dans la
transparence et ce sont les français qui
choisiront au mois de novembre par
rapport au programme qui leur seront
proposés répondent oui que on ou des
peines pays des bisounours inquiet pas
tout à fait quand même la france
d'aujourd'hui dit c'est le dire
d'ailleurs il faut quand même se
rappeler dans quel état nicolas sarkozy
a quitté le pouvoir 600 milliards de
dettes quand même si c'est ça un heureux
bilan je pense qu on a matière à a
encore une fois à interpréter les choses
différemment
moi je me bats je pense qu'il ya
évidemment
une analyse à faire sur le quinquennat
qui s'est déroulée ça ne me satisfait
pas je vais pas vous raconter dudit soi
et tenir une telle vente de bois que
celle que je viens d'entendre il ya un
instant je dis simplement qu'à un moment
donné il ya un droit d'inventaire qui
doit se faire devant les citoyens et les
citoyens sont en capacité parce qu'il
faut les respecter
de faire un certain nombre de choix pour
éviter que par défaut par dépit et par
amertume il aille se précipiter pour
partie vers le pire
regardez quand même les les analyses
électorale la translation du vote vers
le front national
elle vient d'abord de votre temps c'est
quand même pas pour rien que je voulais
dire c'était que la fin de cycle qu'ont
en train de vivre une fin de cycle qui
vient de loin est on en train de
réfléchir à douter à faire évoluer les
institutions avec des nouveaux outils et
je pense qu'il ya la primaire la
question de la primaire participe à sa
encore une fois c'est pas une fin en soi
donc ça c'était la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est quand même tout
cela parce que depuis qu'on a commencé
notre débat on est très dans
l'enveloppent voilà mais la question
c'est pour faire quoi
et si nous on sent de notre primaire on
n'est pas capable enfin de notre
primaire élargie ouverte sur la société
il faut qu'on soit capable de définir
des priorités fortes qui puisse
rassembler les français et les priorités
fortes
il faut quand même qu'on se le dise
aujourd'hui 26 mars c'est la question de
l'union européenne on est quand même
dans un contexte qui est fragile qui est
compliqué qui est dangereux aussi
c'est la question du changement
climatique et c'est la question de la
rénovation démocratique au sein de
l'union européenne bien évidemment et
que la france doit aussi pouvoir porter
à partir de là faire adhérer
enfin m au coeur du débat ces trois
propositions
ces trois priorités que chez les
écologistes en gros on est tous on
partage tous ensemble là pour le coup il
ya consensus
c'est aussi une façon de de remettre les
choses en perspective et de ne pas
confuse et le débat c'est à dire
qu'encore une fois la présidentielle les
primaires ce n'est pas une fin en soi
c'est pour quoi faire et quels projets
mais pardonnez moi
là pour être avocat du diable ça va vous
permettre de rebondir dessus christine
robin mais en même temps dans toutes les
primaires précédentes les gens ont voté
à la primaire pour le candidat ou la
candidate la mieux placé dans les
sondages de l'élection qui suivait c'est
à dire que primaires présidentielles
c'est le mieux placé dans les sondages
d'élection présidentielle c'était le cas
françois hollande qui a été lu au final
c'est ce que disent beaucoup de gens et
fascinant bas vous n'êtes pas d'accord
il n'est pas d'accord formel mais oui
mais je crois que encore une fois ce qui
est important aussi c'est de se
rassembler autour des idées parce que
derrière l'élection présidentielle il ya
d'abord un projet est un projet de
société qui est déclinée d'une certaine
façon et les assemblages un peu
hétéroclite qui peuvent naître des
primaires parce qu'à un moment donné
faut trouver un consensus
il faut réussir à rassembler le plus
large mais si ça ça ne repose pas sur un
socle de valeurs communes sur des
convictions propres et sur des
engagements qui doivent être tenus en
l'avenir
ça déstabilise les gens je pense que
c'est typiquement ce qui s'est passé sur
ce mandat ou globalement bas c'est bien
il ya eu une primaire de la gauche il ya
eu un rassemblement il ya une élection
gagnée
sauf que derrière visiblement la
politique était mis en oeuvre ne
correspondait pas fondamentalement à
celles sur lesquelles ils s'étaient mis
d'accord dans le cadre des primaires ça
ça désoriente tout le monde y compris
l'électorat de gauche et je pense que ce
n'est pas bon parce que ça n'empêche ça
ne permet pas à la limite au
gouvernement fasse de mener aussi
peut-être une politique efficace donc
tenant en compte
prenons en compte ces différents échecs
et puis c'est la peau si c'est la
position tout cas du lit qui est de dire
je récuse le terme de manoeuvre parce
que d'abord je le trouve pas forcément
ils n'apportent rien au débat et je dis
simplement qu'à un moment donné c'est un
niveau d'exigence qui est là et que
l'udps et y fait partie de la famille de
la droite et du centre est clairement
mais qu' on ne peut pas s'engager dans
la primaire s'il n'y a pas au départ un
accord encore une fois sur un programme
sur du contenu et avec certaines
garanties que ce qui aura été décidé
sera mis en place derrière sur du
programme est juste avant de donner la
parole ce niveau m et aussi sur des
investitures aux élections législatives
on va pas se mentir
maintenant on a bien dans un accord de
gouvernance on est d'accord mais aussi d
investiture qu'il faut que le parti
continue à exister c'est la juste
représentativité de chacun c'est normal
d'accord
dans les cours de l'assemblée nationale
ces derniers jours j'entendais beaucoup
quand même et collègue centriste et
républicaine dire à combien va-t-il
falloir trouver un accord combien
c'était le nombre de circonscriptions de
séquences on débattait beaucoup mais bon
et je moi je voudrais revenir à la
question des primaires et à la question
de l'évolution dans le cadre des
primaires la dernière fois je rappelle
que françois hollande n'était pas de
champion des sondages
au début de la primaire et qu'il a
progressé fortement dans le cadre de la
primaire comme d'autres d'ailleurs ont
pu progresser notamment en eau
montebourg d'ailleurs qui avait qui
avait utilisé cette tribune mes yeux
quand même dans les projections pour
l'élection présidentielle très bien
placé et passent pas patte dans les
toutes premières dans les toutes
premières il était quand même de celui
qui venait juste après à faire à
souvenez vous quand même que martine
aubry tenait le parti socialiste à
l'époque et qu'elle avait une capacité
aussi à rayonner moi je pense beaucoup à
la nécessité de faire les primaires les
plus ouverte possible les primaires de
toute la gauche puisque ces montants des
primaires qui vont nous engager certes
sur le débat lié à l'europe parce que
c'est fondamental parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a une rare données - europe écologie
va pas y aller à votre honneur ni et
jean luc mélenchon a déjà dire s'ils
veulent moi je n'avais pas moi je n'ai
pas entendu je sais pas non dans notre
primaire là l'appel qui a été lancé au
mois de janvier
il ya un comité de coordination dans
lequel il ya les représentants du parti
socialiste du parti communiste
d'ensemble d'europe écologie les verts
n'avaient parlé mais pas participé à
leurs noms mais attendait la dernière
fois on voit alors là on arrive par un
petit rappel historique la dernière fois
nous on est parti au printemps sur la
primaire et rappelez vous au printemps
2011 était le candidat du parti
socialiste était dominique strauss kahn
donc il ya eu il ya eu le carton jaune
pâle cartonne new york
york sas a secoué tout parti socialiste
ils ont su un jeu je m'excuse auprès
d'une bonne elle de parler à sa place
ils ont su rebondir sur la prise d'armé
mais voilà ça ça
les équipes ont dû changer etc c'était
aussi ce sera fait ce truc là quand même
oui ce qui en fait la primaire à gauche
elle est actée donc à je ne sais pas
comment je ne sais pas vu la discussion
que j'entends la cedh est aujourd'hui
fortement souhaitée par les la majorité
regardez les pistes ont parlé d'opinion
nous avons envoyé deux minutes avant 17
ans créé voilà bien moment d'en parler
pour cent des sympathisants de gauche
qui veulent une primaire je ne vois pas
comment n'importe quelle partie
éviterait ce débat là nous aurons des
prix n'est donc qu'une question
jonquilles jus pour exercer pour être
sincère il ya un débat au sein du parti
socialiste sur les modalités des
modalités liées à supprimer ya ceux qui
veulent les faire au sein du parti
sioniste
il ya ceux qui veulent défaire le plus
largement ouverts ceux qui vont savoir
si le président de la république sortant
sur la 5ème minute doit soumettre le
primaire avec ses salles clown tiririca
déjà répondu d'une façon il a dit qu'il
ne serait candidat que s'il y avait un
sélection de la courbe du chômage
malheureusement les derniers chiffres là
dessus on répond pardonnez moi de vous
dire que c'est une façon de ne pas
répondre à ma question est ce que ce
n'est pas une façon d'affaiblir le
présent la république et d'acculer
l'échec de sa politique globale est allé
à des prières mais le pire c'est que
s'il ne va pas se présenter à une
primaire il ne pourra même pas semblé
son camp la vérité elle est là
aujourd'hui il faut qu'il se soumet à
cette règle qu'il scelle d'ailleurs
qu'il a lui-même voté lorsqu'il était
simple membre du parti socialiste
donc pourquoi s'y est indexé antonetti
il n'a jamais dit d'ailleurs qui s'enn
exempterait je pense que la meilleure
façon des rentes à se rassembler son
propre camp
c'est d'abord de respecter ces règles
est-ce que c'est pas une façon de
l'obliger à ne pas se représenter
imposer la primaire pour vous on vous
place dans les frondeurs philippe baumel
on a compris votre position vous
considérez ça doit pas être le candidat
de votre camp moi je ne suis pas trop
d'heures ce qui sont frontières c'est un
fois ceux qui sont au gouvernement parce
que c'est cela qui ont changé de ligne
politique par rapport à ces vous
réveillez vous
oui peut-être d'un fait moi je suis
fidèle à ce pour quoi j'ai été élu et
j'essaie justement tous les jours d'être
dans cette exigence là il ya des règles
quant à connaître dont on a décidé
ensemble il faut qu'elle soit respectée
alors donc de votre point de vue ce que
le président de la république soit vème
république
nicolas sarkozy dans n'était pas
question la dernière fois d'ailleurs
pour lui d'aller aux primaires mais il
veut y aller ça prend une question pas
moi je pense que c'est un aveu de
faiblesse que le président sortant s'il
souhaite se représenter passe par des
primaires c'est un aveu de faiblesse par
rapport à sa personne et c'est aussi un
aveu de faiblesse par rapport à la
politique qu'il mène donc ça veut dire
qu'au sein de son propre camp
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord avec
lui et de façon importante
après il peut y avoir des détails mais
là on est vraiment sur une fracture très
importante
moi je trouve ça tout à fait normal de
faire des primaires quand on est dans
l'opposition
mais quand on est président sortant pour
moi il ne doit pas y avoir de primaire
d'ailleurs quand on prend le modèle
également des états unis il y à une
convention qui entérine la candidature
du président sortant
ça a été le cas avec les démocrates la
dernière fois quand barack obama a
décidé de faire un deuxième mandat et
ç'a toujours été le cas dans l'histoire
donc aujourd'hui des primaires quand on
est dans l'opposition oui quand on est
dans la majorité avec un président qui
se représente non la préserver en fait
la question c'est si on ne peut pas
poser cette question du président
sortant enfin l'impasse sur le bilan une
façon elle le fait que nicolas sarkozy
était été battu en 2012
c'était une façon aussi d'entériner un
bilan complètement catastrophique et que
s'il y avait eu des primaires de la
droite à ce moment-là peut-être aussi
que ça aurait permis aux aa l'ump à
l'époque d'avoir un autre candidat alors
que on a bien vu le phénomène le
processus tout sauf sarkozy qui a aussi
contribué à la victoire de françois
hollande
donc la question du 2 de la personne
présidentiel qui à l'issue d'un
apparaître un plus un parti dans la fac
un vrai public on met président et pré
rempli donc tout d'un coup bah non il
entend que sortant d'antan que sortante
parce que peut-être un jour on aura une
femme aussi a tout d'un coup ne faudrait
pas que il revient vers 2 ils reviennent
devant les français pour être comptable
d'un bilan qu'il a incarné pendant cinq
ans enfin de d'une action du bilan d'une
action qui l'incarné pendant cinq ans
donc je pense aussi que on est
maintenant dans quelque chose
de 13 ans diva lent par rapport à la
fonction présidentielle avec le
quinquennat avec le fait aussi que la
fonction présidentielle se conjugue avec
la fonction du premier ministre donc on
a une gouvernance bicéphale et on voit
bien aussi avec le recul du quinquennat
maintenant comment ça q paralysé que ce
soit à droite ou à gauche parfois
certaines décisions certains arbitrages
dans une concurrence pour la fois
d'argent nous amener sur la suite de
l'émission c'est de ça qu'on va parler
juste après la pause de midi
on souhaite petit quelques instants
juste le temps d information midi et on
continuera juste après année